this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 32.
sitting here with Echo Charles Echo
Charles we got a topic for today to kick
things off a little bit maybe a
universal topic true or false and we
might go deeper than just true or false
because I think this is true and false
and false and true
everyone should know what it feels like
to be in a physical altercation
and have their ass kicked
true or false where you at well I I
think I'm with you there's no it depends
and it depends on what you mean by ass
kicked oh
it it depends and at the end of the day
I think there's a lot of benefit to
having that happen and a lot of benefit
to not having that happen so I am gonna
lean towards the benefits of having it
happen oh and I think one of the reasons
that I'm there
is as you've heard me say many times the
most important quality for a leader or a
person
because I gotta add that this isn't just
about leadership this is a person most
equality important characteristic or
quality for a leader or a person have is
humility
and let's face it
getting your ass kicked is a very
humbling thing
in most cases I suppose in some cases
where you're let's say you're way
smaller
way weaker
or in a really disadvantageous position
and you get your ass kicked that's sort
of like doesn't really count as humbling
in a way in many cases it doesn't count
as humbling because you just didn't
stand a chance and that's the way it is
as a matter of fact if you're small and
you get your ass kicked by some big
person they can look like
it can be worse for them in many cases
this was nice about Jeff Glover going in
tournaments and he'd be all skinny and
small and going against just Monster
dudes and just tapping them out yeah
Jeff glovy yeah and you can watch videos
of that too by the way which is
interesting yeah I was never the best
person to introduce people to jiu jitsu
because I'm too big and they go you're
just big I remember actually I was I was
wrong with a friend of mine named TJ
this was in
19 maybe 1998.
something like that so I'm like a blue
belt but he's
145 pounds right and I had mats at my
house this is in Virginia Beach I was
like yeah come over yeah you wanna and I
would try and get everyone to train with
me I'd like the mailman would come I'd
be like before I was just like that with
everybody
and so you know I said hey you should
really do Jitsu you know come on so we
go upstairs I got the mats upstairs and
we roll and I said and I also my blue
belt so it's not
like right now I would be super chill
right you know I'd be like oh yeah see
that's what's gonna happen but then I
kind of had a little bit more aggression
you know so I was just tapping them out
tapping them out and he immediately he's
not a wrestler or anything he
immediately started talking about weight
classes like I mean obviously with your
weight you know look what are you
talking about dude I just got you in a
chimura by the way I saw a comment on
YouTube about my pronunciation of
Chimera what's the proper Kimura Kimura
Kimura okay
so what am I messing up the you
man don't you like my way a little bit
better uh well better no I like that
it's uniquely your way so I say do what
you did I must have gotten it from Dean
or maybe I got it from five I almost
guarantee you did not get it from Fabio
no no so Kimura that sounds like harder
to say you okay I don't think so I think
you added a another linguistic element
when you add the
camura Kimura yeah only you and life
Batman said and he got it from me he
definitely got it oh yeah
um spreading bad word across the country
uh so humbling it's very humbling I'm
not the best person to introduce it but
if you watch Jeff Glover he's tapping
out monster guys that's got to be very
humbling so
I think it's a good thing in many cases
to get your ass kicked
um I have you know I say this about kids
little kids a lot
do I say Jiu Jitsu is really good for
little kids big kids all kids but what I
say is it is
likely to prevent them from becoming
bullied and it's likely to prevent them
from being a bully stops both because
when you get your ass kicked you learn
what that feels like and most people
most people
that aren't sociopaths go ahead I want
to make someone feel like that yeah
right because you realize how
humiliating it is because we've talked
about this before too what's the line
between humbling and humiliating yeah
right I mean we talked about that
because Dean one day I mean many days
Dean's like humiliated me on the mats of
Justice Beyond humbled as humble's like
oh man you know that goes all over me
today dude yeah this man you know gotta
train more humiliating Zach maybe I
don't want to do this sport yeah I hope
nobody saw that I'm gonna get a gun
they're coming to shoot Dean Lister in
the knee yeah let's see what you got now
homie so
let's say this let's try if I tried to
answer this for real I would say
everyone should train
everyone should train Jiu Jitsu everyone
should occasionally
put on the big gloves and do
some kind of MMA type sparring because
otherwise you think your guard is good
to go and then someone starts dropping
bombs on you yeah and that's not cool
and you realize oh Jiu Jitsu is not
quite what I thought it was because this
guy's punched me in the face yeah
yeah interestingly when I first started
that was the whole gen well I when I
started I did it because I wanted to be
an MMA fighter so when we started
training all nogi it was like
MMA training was essentially had actual
mmh it was like half of the training and
then it wasn't until I found out there
was like um tournaments like did you do
tournaments like oh shoot we can do just
Jiu Jitsu whatever and then it was you
know my attention but it was my point is
it was were you thinking that you're
gonna become an MMA fighter yeah that's
the whole reason I joined oh yeah and I
trained for like
probably like
probably like three years I was training
all Jiu Jitsu and MMA they was like
comprehensive that's before you met me
that was before we came here yes before
we came to we trained at City we trained
at boxing club what how many times
like a small amount of times I remember
training with you at the boxing club one
time oh my first time but very quickly
thereafter we moved here to Victory MMA
yeah that was like 2001 eight right yeah
2007 we were training here but it wasn't
open yet but we had mats up and we were
all trading yeah yeah so I did probably
I was training with like googly
um remember Tom Watson Kong I would like
train with him
and he I think I think he fought in the
UFC right at the top and then um yeah
like a lot of guys Joel tutor was there
it was yeah it was like there was a lot
uh Akbar it was like I trained with him
a lot but yeah so he was like a sock bar
but the point is early like when we
started there was a lot of that that
went on punches like you know how to
train with punches I think Scott Catlin
was in there too a lot of time so um
yeah we knew this is what was his uh
fighting name Scott Catlin or Caitlyn he
had some good I forget what his fighting
game was get some nickname oh I don't
know I forget I forget it was one that I
said that's pretty good
remember that fighter whose nickname was
damn
I can't think of this name
it was really long it was like five
different words wait his nickname was
the nickname was
the longest nickname I don't know uh
black guy he was on Art no he's UFC oh
he's like UFC he didn't have that many
fights either he didn't his nickname
didn't really hold up as well as you
wanted it to right got it no can't
remember uh but but as far as training
with punches and knowing you know where
hey your guard is not going to be as
effective if you're going a little bit
more full speed or more full contact or
whatever
um that came through early development
so I think it's like more like I take it
for granted I think a lot of times that
nowadays where Jiu Jitsu is so much more
expanded and so some people can go
through Jiu Jitsu all the way up to you
know a high level without that training
at all
um I could see how how they might be
vulnerable just from a habitual
standpoint you know you have the base
ingrained yeah Concepts in your brain
yeah so when we and oh Greg McIntyre
trained with Love Drake McIntyre punched
me the hardest ever been punched in the
straight Square in the face too by the
way
oh what do you mean like what's going on
what position oh I was in I he was in my
guard what made okay go ahead and I
separated and I went for double you know
you separate garden and then flip over
and go for a double and right when I
flipped over he was like already based
and I remember you had white gloves on
and brought his like he hit me right
between like you know right between the
eyes like a cartoon like a boom it was
at the end of your head I was about to
ask you what was the end of the MMA
career but then I was like oh he's about
to tell me what the end is it just sort
of faded out like I'd jump in like you
know how you're actually training for
maybe you'll get a pancreation match or
something like this and then you don't
and then you're kind of training just
here and there and then you I remember
the last MMA thing that I remember was
less training with Dean to help him for
a fight that's it so it's like it
becomes that you know I just remembered
that guy's nickname Sho Nuff the master
that was the dude's nickname she was
like Fred show
I thought that was a pretty epic
nickname well showing off the master
that's from Bruce Lee Roy right what's
that one last year or The Last Dragon
yeah yeah
the amount of rounds I have fighting MMA
is a lot right so it's like habitual
because the all the sparring that we
used to do
so back to this question trying to bring
it back
um I think everyone should do it I guess
I guess my answer is true now does this
mean you should go out in the street and
pick fights with big people that are
gonna kill you or beat you you know
unconscious no that's why we love Jiu
Jitsu that's why we love MMA because
these things are humbling you get these
things without having to get in a legal
situation without having to get in a
medical scenario right so instead of
this question being should everyone know
what it feels like to be in a physical
altercation to have their ass kicked it
just should be should everyone train Jiu
Jitsu MMA and the answer is yes I think
we can settle it down like that I think
I just kind of solved our problem
yeah in a way and again that's why I was
like it depends and then so the word
should right should it's like if you
don't you're kind of like not doing the
right thing almost kind of thing you
should do this versus shouldn't do this
maybe yeah if you change that more
accurately put it this way is there
immense
value in getting your ass kicked
the answer is yes I would say yes pretty
much across the board as long as you're
not you know whatever right right but
there's a difference between ah you know
I went on the mat with Dean he tapped I
I don't train Jiu Jitsu I show up this
is the reality I show up to train Jiu
Jitsu or Jeff Higgs shows up at my house
I have a little tiny bit of training
he's been training for the last three
years hard he just got his purple belt
and he comes up and kicks my ass with
Jiu Jitsu he didn't hurt me he didn't
send me the hospital but he kicked my
ass for sure yeah
I guess there's a line right yeah what
are we talking about here yeah because
kicking someone's ass could be this
person's in the hospital
yeah and it could be oh I tapped this
guy out nine times yeah which is what
Higgs it to me or nine or 17 or
something yeah Jiu Jitsu is a little bit
different in training
um even in a competition Jiu Jitsu
because it's like there's rules and
there's a clear like it's 100 up to you
when the fight can just stop you can
just tap out and be like hey and it's
not really a real fight like you guys
are
actually I want to hurt this guy I want
to try to like beat this guy up you know
where if you get enough fight somewhere
outside of training or whatever with
somebody especially somebody you don't
know or even if you know him whatever
yeah he's like kind of trying to hurt
you you know and that's a different
experience it's a whole different thing
really because Jiu Jitsu kind of bleeds
more into the you just lost in the
competition even in training the element
of competition that's in training you
just lost that competition you know it's
there it's I don't think that's what
he's talking about at all
I think they're two different things as
far as experience goes like if you
experience getting your ass kicked in
Jiu-Jitsu training in tournaments or
whatever that's not not the same not the
same at all as far as what I think you
know what I think he said yeah have you
ever gotten your ass kicked in a street
fight yes sir uh well here's the thing
depends on what you mean by aspect where
I lost I I've been a street fight as a
kid
teen
I didn't lose that one but the one where
I lost the fight like dang I got beat up
and I'm the one who kind of eaten it I
didn't start the fight but I initiated
the physical part of it right I got beat
um but I didn't get like hurt or nothing
did that impact your yes for your
personality your mentality a little bit
I got my ass kicked I think it was in
fifth grade and
um
you know fifth grade how old are you in
fifth grade
10. 10 ish really
maybe it was sixth grade yeah
maybe it was sixth grade but I think it
was fifth grade anyways I was talking
[__] do you know what I mean and I was a
[__] talker as you know yes sir as you
also know and I was explaining to you
earlier I can't do that anymore like I
don't it's not the right thing to do
right it's not the right thing to do to
ridicule people and make fun of them in
the SEAL Teams it's the only thing
that's what it is all day long every day
but even in the SEAL Teams once I became
an officer once I was
you know when you're in a platoon
Commander you can't just verbally Hammer
someone
because you have too much power and
authority because you're the platoon
Commander as a task you're great you
can't do that stuff anymore you can't
yeah I'm not saying I never did because
sometimes I would be out of line sure
but if you compare to that when I was at
E5 mafia guy in a seal platoon bro I
mean the whole it was it's just ruthless
savagery all the time 24 7. and
especially because then when you're an
E5 and a super tune you're kind of the
you're the opposite power it's the it's
a power inversion so all power is kind
of gained
through that situation the only Power
you have is what you can
muster up with your mouth right talking
[__] to people so I was a little kid and
I was talking [__] and uh
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground